in an effort to not have challenging
conversations in this day and age it's
like well you do you like whatever's
best for you but then what if best for
you is actually harmful to yourself and
or others
remember to
my health
is a top priority in my life
[Music]
you never know how bad you feel until
you start feeling better than you've
ever felt in your life and i've been on
both ends of the spectrum and damn it's
very different to now being like really
focused on the mind body and soul and
like really having all parts
just as equal as the others for me i am
a cancer survivor and so
my entire life now is about making sure
that i have a life you know to continue
so i was diagnosed with lymphedema at
age three which affects the circulation
for me through my legs and feet so
health for me has always been at the top
of my mind because if i don't take care
of my body like my i could have an
amputated foot or leg so it's nothing
that i play around with all of my family
almost has suffered from diabetes heart
disease and stuff like that so that's
why i'm extra conscious about my health
because i don't want to come down with
any of those diseases
i
i've been working out consistently since
i was 19 years old i used to work out
two hours a day but then i realized it's
way too long so now my workout session
with weights are about 45 minutes and
then the rest is stretching and cardio
and i spend a lot of time stretching
because it allows me to get in the zone
kind of like a meditation of sorts it's
all mental like i go to the gym or
workout or do something kind for my body
in forms of movement every day because
it keeps me sane like if i don't go
there then i feel like something's
missing and i get a little bit depressed
sing it all by myself back
there i was going to the gym really
every day for like six months and then
my life shifted i lost my father a lot
of things happened in my life that um
threw off my whole routine and so the
point when when i was going to the gym
so regularly i felt like my brain felt
happier like i've gotten that feeling
back in other ways i have no desire in
me to change my body in any way i like
when my bucket's a little bigger on that
one not at all
see this is where we're gonna get
because i will tell you not every big
person wants to be small
i am conscious about what i eat
my mom had mean weight watchers in
junior high like so my relationship with
food and what i'm putting into my body
has been like completely can we curse
[ __ ] up like since the very very
beginning i had a severe sugar addiction
since i was a kid and like the binge
eating like it makes you feel like
everything i can't have this this is an
enemy so when i see it and i can have it
i'm like oh i want to eat it all every
day i wake up i have a green smoothie
i'm always very conscious of like what
i'm putting into which i think is i'm
just going to say the controversial
statement i think is something that
people
would never
think is true based off the size of my
body there's so much studies that are
coming out like in terms of like your
microbiome like the microbiome that you
have like you can literally eat green
smoothies and eat like everything you're
supposed to be eating and not lose the
weight because you have an imbalance in
your microbiome and like and then people
who are thin they're just really thin
but they eat mcdonald's every day what
they don't realize is how much they're
clogging their arteries and they die of
heart attacks more than quote-unquote
big people
i received
negative feedback about my body growing
up
there you go
i would have people like some family
members be like oh you look a little
heavier than you did last year and then
other family members that were a lot
more direct like uh when are you gonna
lose the weight and it's been like that
i would say my whole life and then we
got to a point where i was getting
compared to my little sister who's like
beautiful and thin and it's like it is
so hard not to compare yourself to other
people it is so hard to have a healthy
relationship with food and with fitness
and just with other people and it became
so difficult to break out of that and to
really love who i am inside my stepmom
would take like if i had a wrapper of
chips like in my room like she would put
it on top of like
my dresser and say like i'm not the
reason why you're fat this is like it
was all very like but it was super crazy
psychological because i was like we've
never even discussed this before
i'm from texas we all eat soul food so
everybody was eating the same [ __ ] food
so my mom 250 pounds my brother 350
pounds but i saw i was eating the exact
same foods and i didn't even know until
i got around los angeles health
conscious people i'm like what what you
mean to tell me you don't have freaking
bacon cheeseburger every single day i
didn't know so like when you got to like
what triggered it in your head that said
oh this to me is the right way for me to
look i wanted to i wanted to be a model
the idea that you wanted to become a
model and the only idea of model to you
meant being thin or fit or whatever that
beat means all i saw because it wasn't
as popular like plus size wasn't popular
back then when i was 18 years old plus
size is definitely not so popular but
it's still it still opened up way more
conversation the conversation i will say
is much more broad now i feel like we're
able to talk about these things a lot
easier now than we were before
but
what the actual way that the industry
treats plus size models is totally
different
sometimes people use being body positive
as an excuse not to take care of
themselves
this question makes me
very passionate this is really big for
me because i've been like come forward
from other body positive influencers but
i feel like that messages other people
put out are very dangerous to a young
woman who thinks that it's okay i don't
care what size you are it's not okay to
sit and eat cheeseburgers and ice cream
all day like that has nothing to do with
your size
i think there's a difference between
acceptance and agreement so like you can
accept your body and be in disagreement
with the health situation that you have
right like we hear fit experts always
saying be skinny lose weight that's the
healthy weight yeah like you can clean
up your body if you're fat at least we
don't say be fat because it's better for
your heart it's better for your soul
it's better for your you know honestly
even what you just said like body
acceptance versus body agreement like to
you you might see one of us and be like
oh they love their accept their bodies
but i'm sure they don't agree with what
it looks like i mean i i wouldn't know
unless i talked with someone but like
whatever the number like whatever like
is coming up in terms of like you know
when you go to the doctor like at the
end of the day that's not even even
better as fit people when you see a
person who is overweight or fat or obese
however you want whatever term you want
to use what's the first thing happens in
your head do you think like oh like it's
great that they accept themselves but
they could use to lose weight or what is
your first thought
my very first thought no no one's like
born that way so you you like there's
habits and things that you observe but
you actually can be born without like we
could eat the exact same thing and be
two different people it could be how
you're raised parenting and stuff like
that i didn't really know what to expect
today i didn't know how the body
positive individuals were going to come
across i didn't know if they were for a
healthy lifestyle or not but i think
it's beautiful that you guys acknowledge
how important it is to keep yourself
healthy
do i feel like there are people in the
body positive community that say well
i'm just happy being fat and i'm just
going to lay down and just do that
yeah absolutely absolutely you ha
fat pride hashtag fat pride is like was
something that was going on for a little
while it's just bodybuilding
buzzword that everyone just throws out
exactly if you said something at some
point that body positivity and like
health and stuff is different like is
that what everybody thinks the actual
body positive community was created to
give a platform to bodies that have been
marginalized in our society that's what
it was actually created for big bodies
disability super skinny bodies
and i want to scream because i'm like
actually this is not meant for you this
is meant for bodies who who don't have a
voice the fitness community is the
reason why the body positive community
exists and i think that
as a community it's important for you
guys to be a little bit more inclusive
people come up to me
[Music]
it was really great talking with you
guys on that i think we really did find
a middle ground um but we did i think we
all realized that it's like not it's not
this line this isn't a lot of pride and
ego out let's freaking talk no i love
how the actual line it was actually on
this side and this time
hey guys jason from jubilee here we hope
you enjoyed another episode of middle
ground honestly this is one of our
favorite series to make and we hope you
enjoy it too let us know in the comments
below what you think about this issue
and if you agree or disagree with anyone
um as always make sure you click here to
subscribe click here for more videos
follow us on instagram and we will see
you guys later